هنا غزه حيث انطلقت عمليه الطوفان الاقصى
ولكنها قد لا تكون نقطه المواجهات الوحيده
ففي شهر ابريل نيسان الماضي حذر وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي من ان تل ابيب لن تشهد
في المستقبل صراعات محدوده على جبهه واحده
بل سيتعين عليها مواجهه تصعيد متعدد
الجبهات سيكون فيه تهديد حقيقي على جميع
الساحات بعد اسبوعين من الحرب الاسرائيليه
على غزه ابرز الساحات التي يمكن ان تمتد
اليها
الحرب جبهه الضفه الغربيه تشهد الضفه
توترا مستمرا منذ بضعه اشهر واتسع رقات
الغضب الشعبي نتيجه الاعتداء على غزه ما
قد ينذر باشتعال تلك الساحه وشن عمليات
فدائيه في داخل المستوطنات او تستهدف
حواجز للجيش الاسرائيلي من اجل زياده
الضغط عليها وتخفيفه في المقابل عن
المقاومه في غزه اذا شنت اسرائيل اجتياحا
بريا للقطاع عرب 48 قد تكون الجبهه
الداخليه في اسرائيل الساحه الثالثه
للمواجهه وذلك اذا ما شهدت اندلاع تظاهرات
على غرار ما حدث في عام
2021 ولكن الاخطر على اسرائيل هو امتدادها
الى المدن العربيه مثل الناصره ومنطقه
المثلث او الى المدن المختلطه مثل حيفا
ويافا الرقعه قد تتوسع لتشمل جبهه رابعه
في جنوب لبنان اذ استهدفت قوات الاحتلال
محيط بلدتي كفرشوبا وشبعه على الحدود
اللبنانيه وقصفت اطراف بلده ميس الجبل
بالقرب من منطقه كروم الشرقيه واطراف وادي
هنين قبله اضافه الى قريه حلتا ومحيط
مزرعه وادي الخنسه بحسب مراقبين قد يدخل
جنوب لبنان في مواجهه مفتوحه اذا طال امد
العدوان او اذا اقدم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي على الاجتياح البري لغزه اما
الجبهه الخامسه فهي مرتفعات الجولان اذ
كشفت مصادر ان القصف فيها بدا من الجهه
الغربيه لمحافظه درعا المحاذيه للجولان في
رساله انه بالامكان ان تكون الجولان هي
الجبهه
الخامسه